la grèce ne fait pas exception comme
partout en europe
l'épidémie de kobe 19 progresse avec 667
nouveaux cas enregistrés ce mardi le
pays doit s'adapter à la pandémie
mardi à athènes l'organisation nationale
de la santé publique a ouvert une
installation de tests rapides dans la
station de métro syntagma qui est l'une
des plus fréquentées de la capitale
ces tests doivent permettre au
gouvernement d'obtenir des informations
statistiques
vous savez très bien que l'on des gros
problèmes au niveau international c'est
de savoir combien de citoyens utilisent
les transports en commun pendant la
pandémie de kovy de 19
il est donc important pour nous pour des
raisons scientifiques et des raisons de
santé publique de savoir quels sont les
pourcentages d'échantillons positifs et
négatifs
quelles sont ces pourcentages l'adresse
voit le nombre de sa population
contaminée augmenter de manière
importante depuis la fin de l'été
depuis le début de l'épidémie le pays a
enregistré plus de 26000 cas pour
freiner la propagation du virus le
gouvernement à décréter de nouvelles
mesures locales dans les régions les
plus à risque les transports en commun
sont limités à 50% de leurs capacités
il en va de même pour les restaurants
bars et cafés
ces derniers ayant aussi pour obligation
de fermer tous les soirs à minuit